fans of the marvel cinematic universe
love to dig through their favorite
movies for easter eggs and references
but some hidden secrets are harder to
find than others here are a few deep cut
easter eggs that took audiences multiple
years to discover
as the very first film in the marvel
cinematic universe iron man has a lot of
differences from the dozens of
expansions sequels and spin-offs that
followed it there's references to real
world conflicts no team-up action and
wait wait a second that's not don
cheadle one thing the mega franchise has
had since the very beginning however is
plenty of easter eggs and hidden
references to reward the most perceptive
fans the hidden details in iron man are
many but that doesn't mean they were all
easy to find in fact one particular
easter egg took fans a good decade to
discover tony stark's final adversary in
iron man is obadiah stain his former
mentor and the manager of stark
industries he starts out as a fairly
jovial presence propelled by that
trademark jeff bridges charisma that
even shines through stains immaculate
suits and chrome dome but there's a
sinister reality underneath in fact
stain was actually the one who planned
tony's kidnapping at the hands of the
mysterious ten rings organization in an
attempt to take the ceo position for
himself in the film's explosive climax
stain ends up donning the iron monger
suit and giving tony his first taste of
super villain combat in 2018 reddit user
hello to horse noticed that stain
actually foreshadows his true intentions
around an hour into the movie simply by
sitting behind a grand piano and playing
a peppy little tune while the scene
might look unassuming the man behind the
composition stain is playing is actually
antonio salieri an 18th century composer
who is depicted as the killer of
wolfgang amadeus mozart in the 1984 best
picture winning film amadeus while
there's no actual historical evidence
that salieri killed mozart in real life
the version of the composition played by
f murray abraham does mirror stains arc
in iron man eerily well after all both
stane and salieri are older less
brilliant talents who envy the prestige
of younger more celebrated geniuses to
the point that they start plotting their
respective downfalls
the first guardians of the galaxy is a
treasure trove of hidden references many
of which director james gunn has long
refused to point out not even to chris
pratt and other stars of his own film
although the movie came out in 2014
there may still be secrets just waiting
to be discovered as gunn has teased for
years that a massive discovery has gone
unnoticed for some time in april 2020
however the director did admit that a
large part of the final major guardians
of the galaxy easter egg had been
discovered some think that it might hint
that peter quill's mother meredith
played by laura haddock is actually a
cosmic force known as eternity that
embodies the universe itself the jury is
still out on whether or not that's
actually the case but fans have
certainly received their money's worth
of easter eggs from the blockbuster
ensemble comedy in 2018 four whole years
after the film's release gunn confirmed
a hitherto undiscovered easter egg in
which stan lee's cameo scene subtly
features lee's famous catchphrase
excelsior written in the skrull language
as recently as february 2021 the
director took to twitter to shoot down a
theory that an image of peter's father
ego was hiding in meredith's brain scans
and casually revealed that the brain
scans originally contained yet another
easter egg which may or may not actually
be in the final cut and that's not even
counting guardians of the galaxy vol 2
which has its own host of secrets for
inquisitive fans to uncover after all
these years i've found you
february 2nd 2018 was a good day for dr
strange director scott derrickson an
eagle-eyed fan had finally managed to
spot one of his favorite easter eggs
that he had hidden in the film as he
retweeted the discovery derekson
commented i've waited two years for
somebody to notice this twitter user tim
d lyden was the first to point out the
easter egg which reveals that one of the
most dramatic events in the movie the
car accident in which doctor strange
severely injures his hands happens on a
very particular date as dr strange
decides which of his expensive
timepieces to wear to the conference he
would end up crashing on route to a
quick glance at his watch face reveals
the date to be february 2nd a holiday
known as groundhog day while groundhog
day is a very real holiday in which a
rodent in pennsylvania predicts the
weather for the upcoming season it's
also the name of the legendary 1993 time
loop comedy starring the equally
legendary bill murray as a weatherman
sent to poxytoni to cover the annual
festivities murray's character phil
connors finds himself reliving groundhog
day over and over again doomed to spend
eternity reliving february 2nd unless he
can somehow find a way out the reference
is more than just an allusion to the
comedy classic it's also a subtle hint
at the good doctor's future after all
doctor strange eventually wins his
seemingly hopeless face-off against the
mighty dormammu by trapping the powerful
villain in a groundhog day style time
loop dooming it to live their
confrontation over and over again until
it becomes frustrated and gives up
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite marvel movies are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]